(bell ringing)
(cheerful music)
- [Voiceover] How many times do you get
one of the only people in the
world doing what you're doing?
There's other people that tried it,
but they haven't lasted.
- My name's Art Ritchie and I'm one of
the co-owners of the Carousel Works.
- And I'm Dan Jones,
and I'm the other owner
of Carousel Works.
- [Art] We're the largest manufacturer
of wooden carousels in the world.
- Art and I met through a
third party that we both knew.
I went over to his shop one day,
and we were talking and
one thing led to another,
and from there it just kinda took off.
I was doing restoration
and he was doing carvings.
- We've had a 50/50
partnership for 30 years,
and there are very few partnerships
that last over three years, so.
- You know that's not
to say that we haven't
had differences over the years.
It's just like being married.
But not that bad.
(laughter)
- [Art] We average, in different stages,
probably three carousels a year.
- [Dan] We're actually
working on four right now.
We have carousels all around the world.
- [Art] We made the Cincinnati
Riverfront carousel.
- [Dan] We have one in the Bronx Zoo.
- [Art] We have one in
the Kansas City Zoo.
- [Dan] the Nashville Zoo.
- [Art] the Atlanta Zoo.
- [Dan] the Riverbank Zoo.
- We even made the Smithsonian
National Zoo carousel.
Carousels will put people
in the eye of the child.
- Oh, they're absolutely beautiful.
When you watch people ride a carousel,
the kids are just loving
to go up and down,
and with these big smiles.
And then the ride comes to a stop.
Can we go again?
It's fantastic.